I got an email from a guy I went to high
school with, right? Email said, Kev,
it's time for you to get yours. I open
up the email. It's two pictures in an
email. One picture was a real little
man standing next to a doctor.
He was angry. Next picture.
That same little man was taller than
the doctor. He was giving a thumbs up.
Bottom of the email said, Kev, it's
time for you to get yours.
I'm confused. What the f*** is going
on? I call him Yo, I got your email.
What the f*** are you talking about?
What are you trying to say? I said,
what do you mean, what am I trying to
say? Say exactly what I said.
What is this? What are you trying to
say? He said that they given our
height, go get you some.
F***. You mean they're giving out
height? Exactly what I said.
They're giving out height. They're
taking the fat out of people's backs.
Putting it in their knee.
They take it.
They've taken a fat out of people's
backs, put it in their knee.
He said, Go get rid of your back fat.
Get yourself some inches.
I said I will do no such thing.
Get rid of my goddamn back fat.
43 years old.
I've been five five my whole life.
Five, four, five.
Two and a half. My whole f***ing life.
Have to do no shit like that.
You got to remember, I ain't been on
tour, like, four years.
I can't just walk out this bitch.
Six, six and not say shit about it.
I just walk out.
What up. What up. What up. What up?
What up? What's going on?
What the f*** is going on with you?
Look at his goddamn knees.
What did he do to his knees?
Why? He got all them holes in his back.
What the f*** he do to his back?
You know what I want.
I want people to start thinking shit
through. I want to get back to the
times of people who had patience.
You got to slow down, start thinking
shit through. Stop acting on impulse.
Let's say I go get the procedure.
I come out of it with these new knees
and these long ass legs.
I'm six six. Look at my f***ing knees
in these long ass legs.
But I still got the same arms.
I didn't do shit to my f***ing arms.
I didn't judge it. Now I can't put my
hands in my pocket because I done f***
up. I'm out in this bitch looking like
a T-Rex touching my chest all the time.
Why Kev always rubbing his chest?
Bitch because I misjudged it.
I can't get my hands in my pocket.
You gotta think shit through.
Let's say I go get the procedure.
I got these goddamn new knees, long ass
legs, my f***ing frame.
Look at my chest and my shoulders.
I'm six six, but I still wear a size
seven sneaker. I didn't do shit to my
feet. Now.
I can't support the new body.
My balance is off.
I look like that. That thing to be at
the car dealerships that.
That air, man. Look at me.
You got to think shit through.
Stop acting on impulse.